ينضم إلينا الآن من الرياض
وزير خارجية المملكة العربية السعودية عادل
الجبير وزير خارجية شكرا جزيلا
لانضمامك إلينا لماذا
تدعم الحكومة السعودية قرار الرئيس ترامب
نعتقد أن الصفقة النووية
كانت معيبة ونعتقد أنه
يجب إلغاء شرط الانقضاء.
نعتقد أن التفتيش يجب
تشديده ونعتقد أن الصفقة
لا تتعامل مع برنامج الصواريخ الباليستية الإيرانية
ولا تتعامل مع
دعم إيران للإرهاب
والتدخل في
شؤون دول المنطقة ، فإذا استأنفت إيران الآن
برنامج أسلحتها النووية.
هل ستصنع المملكة العربية السعودية قنبلة بنفسها ،
أعتقد أنه إذا قام بتشغيل برنامج التخصيب الخاص بها
بما يتجاوز ما هو موجود في
ما لديه الآن ، فيجب أن
يؤدي ذلك إلى تفعيل بنود snapback
ودفع جميع الدول الخمس الأخرى إلى
التخلي عن الصفقة وإعادة فرض عقوبات
على  إيران وماذا ستفعل المملكة العربية السعودية ،
سنبذل قصارى جهدنا لحماية شعبنا
إذا حصلت إيران على قدرة نووية ،
فسنفعل كل ما في وسعنا لفعل الشيء نفسه
، أفترض أن هذا يعني أنك ستحصل
على قدرة نووية بنفسك ،
وهذا ما تعنيه